bon maire là je peux t'appeler merluche
on va pas se mentir
ténin les acteurs les plus bankable du
moment tu as joué dans les plus gros
blockbusters américains
je crois pas avoir besoin de les
rappeler jurassica ciabatta sos souris
mes couilles mes couilles
bref tu as une gueule et moi j'ai envie
de te voir sortir de ta zone de confort
je veux que tu te mettre en danger et
ton public veut ça tu vois ça c'est ta
carrière je vais la faire exploser
le projet c'est celui ci chars mission
mille pages de buzz
grosso merdo on prévoit trois fois les
entrées d'avengers games et j'imagine
que tu meurs d'envié que je te pitch le
scénario en gros si ce film devait avoir
une bande-annonce ça commencerait comme
ça ils écoutent marlins je sais que tu
as décroché
tu as fait ta vie à la carrière derrière
toi et j'ai besoin de toi pour une
nouvelle mission il est de retour
ton pire ennemi prédit fred
oui mais là
le freiner frêle une histoire de
vengeance 1 et j'ai vraiment besoin de
le rappeler celui qui a lâchement
assassiné toute la famille durant
étaient 84 notamment son grand oncle crg
alors sac à puces continue à cacher le
cul on était prêt à reprendre du service
alors il sera accepté et est-ce que tu
m'emmènes vieille branche eau mais je
crois que c'est la fameuse merlin mobile
tu veux le garder pendant toutes ces
années
programme bien besoin d'un petit
contrôle technique le retour d'une
légende
[Musique]
un équipement à la pointe de la
technologie cette fois mr là on peut
dire que tu as été gâté collier gps bart
baele modificateur de nuit allemand avec
caméra intégrée entêté la célèbre souris
grenade
ça fait toujours un petit effet et voici
notre toute dernière trouvaille mc jaune
la chatière de secondes tu la pause sur
n'importe quelle surface et hop chatière
et enfin je te présente la toute
nouvelle merlin mobile lance missiles
latéraux siège éjectable ne la griffe
pour monter aux arbres blindage étanche
en fibre de carbone projecteurs pour le
maire d'un signal radar anti souris et
comme tu peux l'entendre elle est bien
sûr équipé du tout nouveau moteur on
réussisse enfin qu'on pourra conduire il
faut être titulaire du permis b
les gros buveurs d'eau chez anne leeuwen
c'est faux
[Musique]
oui
je pense pas qu'ils bluffent il a une
canne flush royale c'est sûr ok mon pote
c'est le moment d'utiliser des visions
nocturnes de charge contre courant
qu'est-ce qui se passe
agile à l'intrépide
[Musique]
joueurs
m
rapide
[Musique]
déterminée
et
chat en mission bientôt au cinéma alors
tu en penses quoi
bon écoute le contrat est ici testing et
ambac tapas pâte et moi je m'occupe du
reste bon dommage nous allons avec le
fera à sa place
quand je pense qu'on parlait d'un cachet
de plus de 200 micro quête de ton
[Musique]